hey it's just turned four o'clock so
we'll get going I've been doing a
workshop earlier this week I've already
presented 700 slides of code this week I
reckon we have time for another 80 or so
now so my name is Rob small Shire I work
for and part owned a consultancy based
here in Norway we work in various
domains but mostly they have a science
and or engineering flavor to them I've
been working with C++ since about 1995
or 1996 I discovered Python in either
2000 2001 so I've been working with both
these languages for quite a substantial
period of time it's fair to say that my
use of C++ is tailed off in the last
five or six years simply because the
kind of projects I've been involved in
and to use an unfortunate metaphor my
C++ has become a bit rusty so some of
the C++ you here see here it might
remind you a bit more of C++ 98 rather
than C++ 17 so I'm going to talk about
integrating Python and C++ together with
a fair library called PI bind 11 so why
might you want to do this well one of
the key motivations for doing this and
the one that's going to motivate the
example in this talk is that you already
have a useful valuable debugged piece of
technology in one of these languages and
you need to use it from the other one so
in the example I'm going to give them
the talk we have a very high quality C++
library that's been around for a very
long time and I would like to use it for
whatever reason from Python so although
I don't really believe you should ever
design with reuse in mind if you have
something very useful it's much it makes
much more sense to reuse what you
already have rather than trying to
rewrite it from scratch in another
language just because it's another
language
and C++ and Python are interesting
complements their opposite in almost
every way but in spite of the fact that
they live at opposite ends of various
spectrums they do complement each other
very well and they can be made to work
together very elegantly so C++ is very
fast arguably it's as fast as we can go
without dropping down to assembler
Python is very slow very even compared
to things like JavaScript it's very slow
you're looking at Python being nominally
10 times slower than C++ perhaps even
100 times slower so you don't go to
Python for performance on the other hand
as I experienced while I was writing the
code for this talk you don't go to C++
for productivity either it can take a
long time to write the code correctly it
can take a long time that you spend a
lot of time just waiting it's my
experience for the compiler and the
linker so in terms of productivity I
find that I am much more productive in
other languages which don't have that
compile link cycle I can just run code
immediately the whole bunch of libraries
out there for helping you adapt C or C++
code to Python there's one called swig
even the author of swig recommends that
you don't use swig I was I met with him
at Euro Python in Edinburgh a few weeks
ago and over a few beers he confessed
that he wished he'd never written it so
don't use swig as thing called c-types
which is built into the Python standard
library that allows you to call C
functions but not C++ functions there's
a thing called C FF I the C foreign
function interface which is kind of
clever because you can essentially
import a C header file the text header
into c FF I and then call the functions
within it that's quite nice there is
boost Python which is as its name
suggests part of the boost library
that's still very much it
is compatible with C++ 98 and 11 etc but
it's also weighed down by that
compatibility and it's become
extraordinarily complicated and nobody
wants to maintain it the guy who wrote
it is now the lead developer on Swift
for Apple so we're left with PI bind 11
which is much newer has ditched a lot of
the legacy stuff that was really awkward
to do in C++ 98 embraced and embraced
C++ 11 and later coincidentally this
adapter is from the Norwegian Wikipedia
page on adapters and it looks incredibly
dangerous to me how did isolate the
other hot pins when you plug it into one
of them I don't know there were on that
thought let's move on there are two
basic architectures if you like of when
it comes to how we can use Python and
C++ together we can extend Python with
C++ this basically means we can write
Python modules in C++ it's important to
realize that Python is itself written in
C and in fact when you run the Python
executable the Python excusable is a
very small executable and all it really
does is load the Python library libcast
it some arguments and create an
interpreter so once you realize that Lib
python is a c library it becomes a bit
easier to understand how these different
languages can talk together we can write
modules in C or C++ Lib Python will load
them these modules will use the Python C
API Python has a C API for its
interpreter and all of its built-in
types and now C++ modules can also use
existing libraries which might be fed
party libraries as there will be in my
example
or they might be libraries in existing
libraries in your own domain that you
have made the other approach which is a
bit trickier to make it work but it's
very powerful as embedding so you
already have some existing application
in
plus plus say which is using some
libraries and you can have your library
linked against and use lib - and it can
instantiate Python interpreter running
in the same process as your rest of your
C++ application it can then load your
modules written in C++ and your modules
in C++ can call other libraries in your
application or in indeed the original
library in your application all within
the same process so at this point you've
embedded a Python interpreter into a
single program and you essentially have
a single application running in a single
process where you can choose which parts
of it you now write in C or C++ so
that's a typical approach for adding a
scripting facility to an existing
application so for the purposes of my
talk I need an example I need a library
to rap preferably open-source preferably
C++ preferably not entirely
straightforward C++ to make it a bit
more interesting so I've chosen to wrap
a live with some people here might be
familiar with called seagull
Steagall is huge it's the computational
geometry algorithms library it's a good
candidate for rapping it's very fast
it's in C++ it's very robust anyone
who's it don't any computational
geometry will know that writing robust
geometric algorithms is incredibly hard
it's got some very sophisticated
mathematics in it so it knows when
floating-point numbers aren't sufficient
and we'll switch to multiple precision
numbers internally so it's not to lose
precision so clearly right rewriting
something like this or even a small part
of this in Python so that I can use it
from Python is a non-starter Seaguar has
been developed over maybe 20 years or
more so it's a major major undertaking
I'm gonna wrap a very tiny part of
Siegel that deals with a thing called
constrained and conforming
triangulations I is great to use some
C++ I'd like to be able to use them from
pi
so let's go so I'm going to start by
showing you a C++ program which is using
C gal it's an application if you like
and will talk you through what that
program is doing and then when I've
shown you the C++ program we're gonna
set off and try to make that same
program in Python so typical C++ we have
to include a big pile of includes we go
off and define a bunch of types you can
see that these aren't you know entirely
straightforward types you nested
templates many many levels deep here the
key thing is we're creating things like
triangulation data structures and
defining points and vertex handles all
the things we need to interact with the
triangulation here's my main program the
very first thing I do is I create a CDT
that's my type def for a constrained
alone a triangulation in two dimensions
in the next part of my program I'm gonna
have an unrolled loop I wouldn't
normally write code like this but I've
unrolled it for clarity this is the
unrolled loop I'm going to insert a
bunch of points into the constrain
triangulation and each time I insert a
point it returns a vertex handle which
is just an opaque handle on to the point
I've just inserted there are my points
next I'm going to insert some
constraints and a constraint is just a
pair of points that I've already
inserted which define an edge in the
triangulation and they set up a rule in
the triangulation that no triangles are
allowed to cross one of these red edges
here so there's a constraint edges and
while I'm doing this behind the scenes
Seigle is actually maintaining this
triangulation data structure now I'm
going to create a thing called emeasure
you'll notice that the measure is wraps
around the constraint triangulation and
the measure allows me to specify seed so
I've created a vector with two seeds in
it here and I pass the iterators to that
vector to
seeds on the Mesha you can see the two
seed points in yellow here and here and
the seeds allow me to control which
triangles in the triangulation I'm
actually interested in or not interested
in in this case we can strip away the
parts of the triangulation that was no
interest in my picture at least now I'm
going to ask Siegel to make this
triangulation conform to some
geometrical rules to conform to think of
the de Launay property it doesn't matter
what it is but you'll see when I do that
too it says watch here the triangulation
changes and we get some new triangles
and you're now gonna make it conform to
the Gabriel property we get a few more
triangles then I'm going to set some
meshing criteria and I see how to refine
the mesh I'm going to set some
properties that control the minimum
angles on the triangles small angle
triangles aren't very good when you're
using them with simulations and set the
triangle size never get a nice
triangular mesh and then I'm going to
ask the seagull to optimize that mesh
doing a thing called Lloyd optimization
which makes the triangles more even
there we go so there we are beautiful
mesh so the problem is from my point of
view is I'm interested in triangles and
even trivial changes to this program
take me quite a long time it's at least
30 seconds if I just hit compile and run
all right the seagull is not a
straightforward library it's extremely
generic so it takes a long time see you
got also uses boost so it's pretty slow
around this circuit so what can we do
well we can try to wrap it using PI
binary 11 so this is a structure I think
this is one of the hardest things when
you're starting something like this is
how just how do you organize stuff where
the things go you know in a sense
writing the code is the easy bit getting
to this point and ever understanding
where to put things
usually trips me up so I'm gonna have an
example program triangulate PI
I've got PI bind 11 in a Lib directory
I need that I'm going to be using
it I've got the library I'm rapping see
girl that's gonna live in here
specifically this header here and then
I've got my source directory which is
where my rapper is gonna live inside
source
I have measure measure is a Python
package it's just a directory on the
file system that has a thing called this
is pronounced dunder init as a thing
called dunder init PI in that directory
and it has Seagal measure dot CPP which
we're gonna write and then can
optionally have some C++ tests and some
Python tests I need to build the C++
with C make and I need to explain how
that build works to Python with a
standard setup dot pi so let's um let's
just start off watching some Python so
I'd like to do something like this
import measure seagull measure this is
my out to sea Python module this is my
inner Python module which will be
written in C++ and of course I can't do
this yet it doesn't exist so we need to
begin writing some code in here in
seagull measured CPP so this is just
about the simplest pie-by and 11 module
we include pi bind 11 set up the
namespace alias and then use this macro
to set up the module name and M is a C++
object that represents the concept of
the Python module that we're making we
now need to build it so we neither see
make lists I'm no fan at all of C make
its emerges something of a de facto
standard so I'm gonna try to use it and
we have a C make file which says the
project is Seaguar measure we're using
seagull seagull uses boost so we need
that as well
and we're telling it about pi bind 11 pi
by and 11 comes with C make support
which is why I'm using C make and then
all I need to do is use this seagull
function here pi bind 11 add module is
the module name here's where to find the
source code for the module and C make
will do its thing
all Python modules that are packaged up
need a thing called setup type py which
uses setup tools to package Python into
something we can redistribute so I need
a setup dot pi as well set up top PI
files usually pretty simple they usually
look something like this just you know
the name of the module the version who
wrote it
we need to explain in setup doc py that
this code needs to be compiled using a
thing called C make extension
unfortunately we have to write C make
extension which looks like this it's
just horrible
fortunately this is just boilerplate and
you can copy and paste it and you can
copy and paste the other half of it as
well that's quite a lot of code in here
required to make setup tools talk to see
make but you only have to write it once
in fact you can just do what I do and
just cargo cult it and copy it off the
internet so we've come now we need to
run set a block py and when you give it
develop that argument there is usually
things like develop or install develop
means that I want to be able to install
the code in such a way that I can still
develop on it while it's installed into
my current Python so we run this it goes
away set up dot py calls C makes you may
just the compiling and linking we're
done here
it's built that takes about a minute I
start at Python here we are Python 37
import measure so you got measure great
it works we've got the imported the C++
module we ask for help on the module
it's not very interesting there are no
classes nor functions in here yet but
you can see that the module is
implemented as a shared library here on
my Mac normally when your modules
written in Python you get the path or PI
file here so the module is just a
dynamically loaded library so now let's
crack on and start building the mesh
from Python so in my in my little test a
I just did in
poor measure Seger measure and switch
this around so it's from measure Segal
measure import to constraint the law no
triangulation as CDT in Python we can
rename things on import which is very
handy so here's my very basic Python
program those of you aren't familiar
with this this is how you tell Python
what to do when a module is executed and
what it says is when this module is
executed call main in main we
instantiate a CDT and call it CDT simple
ok our module is not very interesting
yet so to get that to work we need to
tell in C++ we need to use high bind 11
to explain that we want to wrap an
existing type CDT and we want to call it
this in Python and it must have a
default constructor okay no it's the
underscore here this is not the class
keyword this is a function within the PI
bind 11 named space but is I hope you
agree that's fairly readable you'll see
why I have this slightly odd placement
of semicolons in a moment so we need all
the we need all the includes and all of
the I've got fancy here in my C++ this
is I've moved away from type deafs you
seem to whatever these are called and
now I'm used it so I need all of this
just to find out what CDT is ok so I can
use it here
okay so next we what do we need to do we
need to insert the points into the
triangulation so I'm just going to take
the same unrolled loop approach that I
took in the C++ so in order to get this
to work what do we need to implement
well we need to be able to import point
so that we can get hold of that we need
to wrap the point class we need to wrap
the insert method on the triangulation
and we need to even though this vertex
handle type is never named in Python
because python is dynamically typed we
need to have wrapped it so that this
function is able to return it because
insert returns this vertex handle so
back to the c++ we're not quite doing
TDD here but we're definitely driving
the implementation of this module by
requirements in the client code so
inside the module we need some more code
now we need the point class so I have to
define the point CDT gives us a type for
that and this is pretty much the minimum
useful point again
PI class I'm wrapping the point I'll in
this module I want to call the point
this in python or to call it point and
I'm going to define an initializer for
it that takes two integers and I can
tell PI bind 11 what I want the
arguments to be named in Python Python
allows named arguments and we can
explain that two pi bind 11 by using
this pi argh
that's pretty minimal I'm gonna go a bit
further I'd also like to be able to
construct my point from two doubles this
is kind of interesting because we don't
have overloading in Python because it's
dynamically typed but when I'm writing a
Python module in C++ I can overload
functions and the machinery is smart
enough to dispatch to the right one
depending on which one I'm using on the
actual dynamic type at runtime
so there's quite a lot machinery in pi
binder
to make all of this work I also want to
add a couple of properties so in Python
we have properties which enables us to
enable us to access the attributes of
objects without going through a function
call okay we don't need the parentheses
on the end I'd like these properties to
be read-only so use def property
read-only
I'd like my properties to be called x
and y what do they do they call these
two functions so here I'm passing a
pointer to point to member function here
okay so whenever I get that property
from Python it will call that C++
function so this is quite nice and it's
quite readable and now you can see why
my semicolon is here because all of this
is one statement and these are chained
method calls make sense now when
everyone teaching my Python classes I
strongly encourage people to implement a
special Python method called dunder
repper underscore underscore our EPR
underscore underscore and then the
wrapper is the special Python method
that gets used to display objects to the
console particularly in an interactive
session and it's much easier to debug
your Python programs if they know if the
objects know how to display themselves
so we're going to defined in the wrapper
here and my dunder wrapper
implementation is going to be a lambda
and I'm going to use some fairly
horrible string concatenation here to
put the description of that object
together so start with a string point
and I'm just going to convert the
coordinates to strings and make it look
nice so it's very important to remember
dunder repper if you want to have a nice
development experience when you're
working from Python especially for a
value type like points here yeah
I do have a comment on that any object
you have in Python will inherit done the
wrapper and then the straw from the
object base class then the wrapper is
really intended for developers and then
the stirrer is intended for the rest of
the human race so that's generally how
you organize things so put that way I
would say you should always have a
dunder wrapper because otherwise you're
going to get the inherited dunder
wrapper from object which just prints
the object address which is not very
useful yeah I'm not going to cover that
today but there is support in PI by and
11 specifically for numpy and some other
very popular numerical libraries yeah so
you can do things like access numpy
array arrays from c++ yeah I'm not going
to show that today though so we also
need to wrap this vertex handle vertex
handle we don't need to say anything
about it all we need to do is be able to
own a vertex handle from Python it can
be completely opaque so this is very
concise we just have vertex handle in
this module called vertex handle okay
and then we need to add the insert
method to our triangulation class so the
insert method here is again bound to
this lambda which just calls CDT insert
why have I used the lambda rather than a
function pointer like I did before it's
because insert is overloaded about 37
times and you have to get into quite
unpleasant syntax casting the function
pointer to explain exactly to 5 and 11
which overload you want to call using
the lambda avoids that and frankly it's
just easier to read
okay so that's inserting the points now
we need to insert the constraints these
accept vertex handles these are pay cob
jects so let's see how to do that
actually let's see that we can't do it
yet because we have no insert constraint
and we run our Python program so insert
constraint is going to look like this
again it's going to be bound to a lambda
that accept to vertex handles and just
calls insert constraint so you can see
most of these wrappers are really
straightforward extremely simple and you
have quite I haven't done it yet we ever
get freedom you can call the method in
Python something different to what it
was called in C++ you'll see that come
up soon for my own convenience and so
that I can debug the thing and make sure
this is actually working I'm just going
to add a couple of functions which get
the number of vertices in the
triangulation and the number of
triangles in the triangulation faces
these are implemented using function
pointers okay let's crack on so now I've
run my program and I've inserted 28
vertices moving forward next thing I
need to do is insert these two seed
points to explain which parts of the
triangulation I'm interested in this is
a little bit more interesting from a
wrapping point of view in Python I'd
like to be able to write this I'd like
to put lights we had to create my
measure create a Python list with two my
points in remember these are C++ objects
this is a Python list containing two C++
objects and I'd like to pass my seeds to
measure dot seeds from to tell the
measure about these two seed points I'd
like my seeds from to be very generic
from a Python point of view so that
seeds can be any Python iterable not
just a list as it is concretely here but
a list a tuple a set just any collection
of points so I'd like this to be quite
generic I struggled a little bit with
this reading the that I have to warn you
the PI by and 11 documentation is not
fantastic it's pretty bare-bones
so you have to spend a bit of time
working things out for yourself
pie-by and 11 gives us an iterator type
which is a wrapper around Python
iterators in C++ it gives us pie eater
which can take an iterable object and
give us a Python iterator what I can
actually do with Pietra at PI a traitor
is a is a C++ iterator wrapper around a
Python iterator right so it looks like
an STL iterator but its implementation
is a Python in for iterator as
implemented by the Python virtual
machine by the Python runtime so set
seeds is just expecting any forward
iterator which has a value type of
points so I can give it my Python
iterator here this actually fails and it
fails because the iterator doesn't know
that its value type needs to be point
its value type is just PI object which
is just the most generic thing so that
doesn't really work to make this work
adapt my Python iterators to my c++
iterators and to write an iterator class
iterate a template class called typed
input iterator and you can see here that
I'm taking my Python iterator adapting
it to my typed in put it rater with a
value type of point and then passing
those iterators to set seeds in c gal
yeah the only thing the only interesting
thing that typed input iterator does is
call this cast function from pi bind 11
just to make the type conversion work
all the rest is just iterator
boilerplate but it works ok now I need
to wrap my conforming delorean
conforming gabriel functions this is
very straightforward the module object
has a def I can give a function name a
function pointer an argument name I
should have done this throughout I
haven't for space reasons but you can
also give
of a docstring and that will be
accessible from Python so when you do
help in Python on your module you can
get the documentation that you've
written on the C++ side of things so
that's quite nice okay so we just run
our program again doing quite well here
so we start off with 28 vertices we do
the de Launay conforming and we get 31
we do gabriel we get 37 so the program
seems to be working that's good now I
need to refine the mesh and for this I
need to wrap this criteria object or
create this criteria object which is a
seagull thing again which the mesh uses
to decide how to do the meshing so back
in C++ we have to write all of this we
have to create the criteria object
notice now new thing here PI R doesn't
just allow me to name the argument
allows me to specify a default for the
Python function from C++ so I can do
default arguments here too which is nice
and then on my measure here I've just
added oh yes I've added def property so
before I had a property read-only this
is a readwrite property where I can set
the criteria the property setter is this
function pointer the property getter
sorry the property getter is this
function pointer the property setter is
this lambda which just falls through to
set criteria again I use the lambda
there to avoid casting function pointers
okay how are we doing
let's run our program again obviously
rather than we just ridding the program
all the time I should have some tests
but then that would be even more code
for you to look at so after the mesh is
done its work we've now got 431 vertices
so everything seems to be working nicely
and then the last thing we need to do is
this mesh optimization step with Lloyd
optimize this is pretty straightforward
actually no it's not straightforward and
it's not straightforward because Lloyd
optimized uses some quite clever
machinery from boost to allow you to do
named arguments in C++ which I won't
even pretend to understand but in order
to wrap it
I had to write all of this in order to
be able to call Lloyd optimize mesh to
again you can see my use of Pi arc here
to specify the argument names and the
defaults so I've got at this point I've
got a thing I've got to the end of my
original C++ program and reproduced it
in Python which is nice
and of course fiddling with this Python
program and running again
takes literally 2 seconds whereas
fiddling with a C++ program I'm running
it again took me at least half a minute
maybe longer right now I need to this
program is great allows me to build a
mesh but I can't now I can't actually
access the mesh I can't iterate over it
or get hold of the triangles or do
anything with them so how do we do that
and we get the mesh out well see gal
defines on its triangulation some
iterator ranges vertices begin to end
and phases begin to end this finite is
here because triangulations have
vertices in infinity for reasons I'm not
going to begin to go into and so what
I'm doing here is I'm saying i want
finite vertices function on my constrain
triangulation object i want it to return
a Python iterator and it's
it's really straightforward to use it
looks like it is I just call make
iterator give it my C++ iterators and it
returns a Python iterator that wraps
them that's really straightforward same
for the faces when I was writing this I
ran into real trouble figuring out what
the value type of these iterators was
because the siegel templates are nested
so deep and I was tracing this through
the code trying to find out what the
value type actually was because I needed
to expose that value type to Python so
that the iterator could be dereferenced
fortunately the solution came in the
elevator this morning which I was
sharing with some world renowned C++
experts he gave me the key piece of
advice I needed and the key piece of
advice is you need to go to stack
overflow and paste in this type name
function which allows you at runtime to
print out as text the actual type of a
thing you have in C++ so I actually
actually wrapped a function called print
faces iterative value type which calls
type name on finite faces iterative
value type because I had no idea what
this type walls and then I was able to
print it out and when I printed it out I
wasn't much wiser so I pasted it into my
text editor and reformatted it and got
this so that was the actual value type
of via tracer which I was struggling to
find so the reason Siegel is like this
is because you could parameterize it on
things like the type of float:right you
can put your own number types into it so
it's extremely generic but I did
struggle with that I admit I got a great
hint this morning in the in the lift
yeah so anyway the truth has work when
she figure out which types you need to
expose another important thing I've
added which you'll see why in a moment
is point is a value type you know we
don't really deal with points by
reference we copy them around okay and
it's very important that for value types
especially for one to use them in like a
dictionary or a set in Python that they
know how to generate a hash code
and equality is defined for these things
so I've had to define dunder hash which
makes a type in Python hashable and then
the EQ so Python understands how to
compare things for equality with the
double equals so you can see they are
left fairly straightforward then the EQ
just falls through to the Equality
operator and C++ then the hash is a
little bit more involved I was very
happy to see that C++ now has a std hash
so I was able to use that to generate my
integer hash code based upon the hashes
of the x and y-coordinates so it seems
to work so now it's slightly more
interesting Python program using all
that stuff so this is a complete Python
program we take in some command line
arguments I get the file name for an
edge file that's going to contain some
edges just some line segments I'm gonna
take in the file name from mesh file
name which is what I'm this program is
going to write out and I'm going to take
in a number which is the size of the
mesh that I'd like to produce I'm going
to create a constrained alone a
triangulation this is my siegel object
created from Python I'm gonna open my
edge file for each line in the file I'm
gonna read the line I'm gonna split it
up put whitespace I'm gonna map each
field to through the float function to
turn it into a floating-point number and
I'm going to unpack the result into a X
a Y B X B Y so there are two points at
the ends of a line segment okay I use
these to create the two points a and B
which I insert into my triangulation and
then I insert the constraint edge
between a and B so these are those two
vertex handles that came back I just
pass them straight back to C gal here I
don't never need to know what they are
they're just completely opaque types
then I refine my triangulation by making
it de Launay compliance and Gabriel
compliant I create my measure just
meshing do the lloyd optimization on the
mesh from at this point I've built a
nice mesh but it's living inside the C++
date
structure so we need to pull it back now
so that we can access it from Python so
what do I do here I build a dictionary
which maps points which are now hashable
so they can be used as dictionary keys
to an index of the point so the first
point is index 0 the second point is
index one I use enumerate to generate
those indexes these that this is the
dictionary key the vertex point this is
the value the integer so for any point I
can say which index are you at so I'm
just building that map in Python that
dictionary in Python then I go through
every triangular face for face in finite
faces here and I ask that face for its
vertex handle at index is 0 1 & 2 so
there are the 3 corners of every
triangle okay and then for the 3 corners
of every triangle I look up in my
dictionary built up here what the index
is so anyone who's ever done any
graphics might know about like V lists
and T lists triangles so we have a list
of vertices and we have a list of
triangles and these triangle is
represented as 3 indexes into the vertex
list quite a simple thing and then we at
the end here we just write out into the
mesh file the number of vertices print
out each vertex the number of faces and
print out each triangle so the input
file to this program looks like this
four numbers per line so that's X Y X Y
four points we read those in from
coaster edges we've run our program
Python make Paramesh pi closed edges to
coast mesh the size of 0.125 for the
triangles it writes out a file that has
89 thousand points in it and 178,000
triangles in it the whole process takes
about a second including all the file
i/o and the triangulation everything
there's no way I could do that in Python
if I wrote that triangle Adrian Python
it take ten minutes
and we get a nice mesh and we're done
with three minutes for questions thank
you
[Applause]
you can just stare at that because it's
beautiful I think if you're gonna do put
my microphone back on so the question is
do I recommend pi bind 11 I think if
you're wrapping C++ today pi bind 11 is
the way to go if you're wrapping see
today then c-types or c FF I might be
sufficient and it's probably possible
quite possibly less work I mean if I
just have if I just had something where
I wanted to call like to see functions I
just use C types because then you don't
need the whole kind of build system
stuff to go along with this and which is
where a lot of the complexity is if I
was doing C++ I'd definitely go over pi
bind 11 I cannot imagine a case in which
I would now use boost Python
I think pi bind 11 is superseded it and
thankfully pi bind 11 api's are very
close to the boost Python API is so
migrating is not free but it's
straightforward
what questions do you have
yes how long did it take to do Sunday
and this morning plus a bit of time on
the slides yes yeah there's no there's
no magical just wrap this class yeah it
does feel like there should be yeah I'm
not sure why that is I mean it's quite
often C++ classes have a lot of stuff in
them that you don't want to wrap you
know and I can you know for example and
when you have like vertex begin and
vertex end I don't want to wrap those
two Python right I want it to appear as
a Python iterator which is just giving
me the all the give me a vertex iterator
so what is two functions in c++ really
has to become one function in python to
be pythonic
yeah I I don't think it's hard I mean
there's a few patterns you need to
figure out particularly with adapting
iterators but beyond that just regular
functions are really straightforward to
to wrap I think so it's it's not a lot
of work you know I be quite comfortable
just well I have done you know just
sitting down and making one of these
wrappers quite quickly where the time
goes is in getting the thing to build
for the first time right that is well on
every project I've ever worked on I
think that's been true so but
particularly so in this case because
there's a lot of moving parts and you
have to worry a lot about binary
compatibility between your library that
you're wrapping and the Python
interpreter and possibly the application
you're embedding it into so you spend a
lot of time worrying about those kind of
things yes correct
I did have an outer Python module which
I didn't use it had no code in it right
you can put code in there and then of
course then you have the opportunity to
write stuff that can be written in
Python in Python yeah I mean you're not
forced to write the whole thing in C++
you can certainly do this kind of mixed
language module where you know certain
aspects of the wrapping if they're
easier to do in Python why not do them
in Python I did have that module in here
it was empty except for in fact you know
by the time I finished it was empty
so but you could put Python code in
there sure to help you do the wrapping
and then you could if you did that
approach you could expose api's that
were less Python accusing pi bind 11 and
then make them fully Python it
in the Python yeah yes my curator if if
the packing side keeps holding that yeah
right had we had we had like another
three hours we could have talked about
all the other arguments that go to PI
make iterator which are various policies
which control the lifetime of the
objects that's being that are being held
onto so there is quite sophisticated
control for object ownership in pi bind
11 because of course you can get into a
fight between the Python garbage
collector and whatever you'll C++ wants
to do in terms of ownership and you do
need to be careful and I will confess
that this example is carefully
constructed to avoid any of those issues
yes yes yeah in gdb it is my colleague
Austin bingum has written some gdb
plugins that allow you to do exactly
that you can step from one language to
the other back into the other language
back into the other I'm not smart enough
to write plugins like that which is why
I work with Austin but you know if
you're in like Visual Studio or
something without gdb I don't my guess
is not
okay are we done thank you all very much
for your attention
[Applause]